we are here in Sacramento California I'm
here in the parking lot of my hotel I'm
going to the restaurant
there's directly next to the BEST
WESTERN PLUS so let's go into the Jay Z
restaurant album The Blueprint just got
in here this is a pretty big booth this
is maybe one of the biggest boost I've
been in so that's that this is good book
I feel like I feel like a little boy
yeah I feel like a kid a little bit The
Blueprint they're keeping on thing with
the blueness and stuff they have some
cool paintings some cool art in here and
Nelson Mandela always that's my boy this
place is called the blue friend jay-z
should buy this and at the opening party
the reopening party him an Eminem should
perform renegade while standing on table
renegades you've been afraid I'm in a
tree so we got salad
tastes legit got a little pepper all in
the Apple or see how that take all right
LC plays welcome salad doesn't how you
[ __ ] it up isn't that having it be fresh
and
mr. wehling but this is where I guess
next level right here
calamari insert a suit
I'll try that and that's what dreams are
made of this is the appetizer aftermath
everything finished except for Marcus's
self but he was filming so he had that
sound but now I'm being the hungry
monster I'm just eating the cheese that
was under the calamari
I think this yeah that's that's it's
good right
that's Parmesan even it's good
no lemon left behind
and even taste of calamari we got steak
comment we got fish coming we got pasta
it's a goddamn rick ross video on this
[ __ ] right now all types of booze all
we mrs. die spine now diced pineapples i
just bought my girl let's set well maybe
like an old rick ross video cuz rick
ross' slimmed down a bit
rick ross to like yeah get got there
naked juice a [ __ ] your girl after we
took a soul cycle class together
yeah we just finished up here at the
gluten-free
restaurant it's Sacramento California
and you know what this feels good do not
judge this place by the fact that it is
located directly next to a Best Western
I feel like jay-z we really enjoyed his
restaurant Beyonce would too blue would
love the calamari the soup was good and
we got a nice salad to start off with
for the main course we shared steak
shared the pasta and a swordfish steak
and pasta were amazing but then the
swordfish was so so so I was I would say
the steak is Batman the pasta was Robert
and his swordfish well the penguin
it was trying to destroy everything that
we worked to us for this meal but
overall feel good I feel full and
slightly energized I don't even want to
take a nap I wanted to go do something
if you're on a date okay you trying to
close up the deal the blue friend is
probably supposed to go have some drinks
and then safely walk over into the BEST
WESTERN PLUS look double double unpaid
plug
I'm just giving ya how many commas Auto
TV yes